a video posted to social media appears
to show Ukrainian troops shooting a
captured Russian soldier I was wondering
if you've seen the video and if you have
a reaction thank you I haven't seen it I
heard about it I want to
reassure you that Ukrainian Army
observes the rules of warfare
there was of course there might be
isolated incidents of the violation of
these rules and they will be definitely
investigated
but uh I wanted to double check the date
of this of this of this video because
you should understand
uh one thing
um now you you will not understand it
I'm sorry
but um
you don't understand how it feels after
seeing uh
pictures from bucha
talking to
people who escaped
uh knowing that the person you know
was raped four days in a row
and when she finally made it to Kiev
she was directly taken to the
psychiatrist
you don't understand how it feels that
Russian soldier rape children
this is not an excuse to those who
violate the rules of warfare
on either side of the front line
but there are some things which you
simply can't understand I'm sorry